Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Azak.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz Arsthetik.
Aufnahmegespräch.
Ja, könnten wir zusammen auf das Aufnahmegespräch hören?
Natürlich gerne.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Na klar.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Peter Schmidt.
Herr Schmidt, könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen bestätigen?
Ja, mein Vornamen ist P.V. Paula, E.V. Emil, T.V. Theodor, E.V. Emil, R.V. Richard.
Nachname ist Schmitz, S.V. Siegfried, C.V. Cesar, H.V. Heinrich, M.V. Marta, E.V. Ida, D.V. Dora, T.V. Theodor.
Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie? Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 71 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 11. Januar 1955.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 Meter groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege ungefähr 80 Kilogramm.
Okay, vielen Dank für diese Informationen. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich ungefähr drei Tage sehr starke Durchfälle habe.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie Durch?
Durchfälle.
Haben Sie Durchfall?
Genau.
Zum Beispiel, wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Ja, ungefähr so sieben bis achtmal.
Haben Sie unangenehm etwas bemerkt? Zum Beispiel, ob Rinde oder Haut?
Ja, das riecht sehr übel.
Haben Sie Farbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfluss, Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe Übelkeit, ich habe auch etwas Fieber.
Ich habe gestern gemessen, das war bei 38 Grad.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, Bauchkrämpfe habe ich.
Wo sind die Schmerzen?
Ganz Bauch.
Unterbauch.
Unterbauch Schmerzen.
Rechtsseitig, linksseitig, welche Seite sind Schmerzen?
Beidseitig.
Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind Schmerzen auf einer Skala von eins bis zehn?
Vorbei zehn untererträglich ist?
Geh bitte.
Wie stark sind Bauchschmerzen auf einer Skala von eins bis zehn?
Vorbei zehn untererträglich ist?
Okay.
Ich würde sagen fünf bis sechs.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein.
Seit drei Jahren haben wir es nicht.
Das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen.
Aber es ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen.
Nein.
Seit drei Jahren haben Sie...
Haben Sie Blut im Schutul bemäht?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemäht.
Sie haben Überkeit?
Ja.
Wie viel Mal haben Sie oder wie oft?
Ich habe Übelkeit.
Ich habe aber nicht erbrochen.
Entschuldigung.
Ja, erbrochen.
Leiden Sie unter Blasungen?
Ja, auch.
Aber der Durchfall ist sehr stark.
Gibt es jemanden in Ihrer Ungewohnheit, der eine ähnliche Beschwerde hat?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewohnt ab oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Appetit ist weniger geworden jetzt.
Haben Sie an Ihrer Haut Farbeveränderungen bemäht?
Nein.
Leiden Sie oder haben Sie Husten, Atemnot?
Nein, auch nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzgupfen, Herzgupfen?
Nein, aber ich habe ein bisschen Schwinde, wenn ich aufstehe und wenn ich mich setze.
Ich denke, ich muss mehr trinken.
Sie haben Schwitzen?
Nein, Schwitzen nicht.
Schwinden, Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Haben Sie eine bestimmte Essgewohnheit?
Nein, ich esse eigentlich alles.
Zum Beispiel Vegetarisch oder?
Nein.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ich schlafe gut, aber ich muss jetzt ein, zwei Mal aufstehen, weil ich Durchfall habe.
Trinken Sie genügend Wasser?
Ich denke nicht, ich muss mehr trinken wahrscheinlich.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerde gehabt?
So starken Durchfall habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Sind diese Beschwerde nach einem bestimmten Essen aufgetreten?
Nein, ich denke nicht.
Zum Beispiel Milch?
Nein.
Oder Brötchen?
Nein, ich habe nichts Besonderes gegessen.
Haben Sie letzte Zeit einen anderen Arzt aufgesucht?
Nein, aber ich war im Krankenhaus vor ungefähr zwei Wochen.
Vor zwei Wochen?
Da war ich im Krankenhaus, ja.
Warum?
Ich habe eine Brunn-Schittis gehabt.
Vor zwei Wochen war ich im Krankenhaus.
Welche Therapie-Massnahmen wurden bei Ihnen durchgeführt?
Ich habe Antibiotik bekommen.
Hatten Sie Probleme nach der Antibiotik?
Hatte ich was?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Herr Schmidt, leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Ich habe das schon seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren?
Okay, noch etwas?
Ich habe Knie-Schmerzen, ich habe Arthrose in den Knien.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ungefähr seit 10 Jahren.
Gibt es noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Das reicht schon.
Was?
Das reicht. Das ist schon genug.
Ah, ich habe fast verstanden. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, mir wurde einmal der Blinden in meiner Kindheit rausgenommen.
Okay, noch etwas?
Nein.
Okay, wurden bei Ihnen außer Brunnschütz im Krankenhaus bleiben oder die Stationäre behandelt?
Ja, ich war stationär. Ich war ungefähr 10 Tage im Krankenhaus.
Ja, außerdem wurden bei Ihnen weitere Stationäre behandelt?
Also ich war wegen einer Brunnschütz im Krankenhaus.
Ah, ja, ich verstehe. Okay. Herr Schmitz, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme für meinen Blutdruck ein Medikament ein und für meine Schmerzen nehme ich auch ein Medikament ein.
Können Sie mir die Namen von Medikamenten sagen?
Erst einmal Amnodipin, 5 mg.
Okay. Wie oft nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Morgen und abends.
Okay.
Dann nehme ich Ibuprofen ein, morgens und abends.
Kennen Sie Dosierung von Ibuprofen?
Ja, 400 mg und ich nehme Pantoprazolein morgens einmal.
Kennen Sie Dosierung von Pantoprazolein?
20 mg.
20 mg. Okay. Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, nicht als Justus.
Okay. Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Das ist sehr gut für Ihre Gesundheit. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gar nicht.
Okay, super.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Dafür bin ich zu alt.
Wann und wie haben Sie konsumiert?
Ich habe nicht konsumiert. Ich bin dafür zu alt.
Ah ja, okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie relevante Erkrankungen?
Ich denke nicht, nein.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind, okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich habe eine Frau, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Gott sei Dank. Herr Schmidt, ich glaube, Sie sind nahe.
Ich bin Retner, ja.
Was haben Sie früher gemacht als Arbeiter?
Ich war Altenpfleger.
Mit wem leben Sie so seit?
Mit meiner Frau.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geächt?
Ja.
Gut, super. Tragen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich gehe sehr gerne spazieren.
Okay.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, ich war nicht im Ausland.
Haben Sie Stress im Privatleben?
Eigentlich nicht. Mir geht es gut normalerweise.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Schmidt, ich habe meine wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich möchte aber, dass Sie mir helfen. Ich bin sehr schwach.
Ja, ich werde Ihnen helfen, wenn Sie sich da keine Sorgen machen.
Bitte legen Sie sich auf die Liege. Ich werde Sie förderlich untersuchen.
Danke schön.
Hat jemand andere Fragen?
Ja, danke.
Bitte schön.
Wie sah Ihr Stül aus?
Flüssig.
Wässrig.
Welche Antibiotika haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich glaube, das war Klindamidzin.
Haben Sie vor oder nach dem Essen Bauchkrämpfe?
Ich habe immer Bauchkrämpfe, die ganze Zeit.
Die ganze Zeit.
Haben Sie noch Auswuchs oder etwas?
Nein.
Keine Lungen Symptome?
Nein. Keine was?
Keine Lungenbeschwerden?
Keine Lungenbeschwerden, nein.
Haben Sie Rohes Fleisch, Mayonnaise, Eier gegessen?
Rohes Fleisch nicht, aber Eier, Mayonnaise esse ich gerne.
Aber das ist nichts Besonderes, das esse ich immer.
Immer, ja okay.
Entschuldigung, wie viele Mal haben Sie die Fieber gemessen?
Ich habe gestern und vorgestern gemessen.
Gestern und vorgestern.
Ich bin bereit.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und möchte ihn Ihnen vorstellen.
Hatten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Sehr schön.
Danke.
Unser Patient heißt Peter Schmid.
Er ist 71 Jahre alt, 1,80 Meter groß und wiegt 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Schmid stellte sich heute aufgrund seit drei Tagen bestehende, persistierende,
progresive, wirkende Tiere vor.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Tiere,
nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Tiere, nein,
nach Angaben des Patienten geht der Patient 7 bis 8 Mal auf die Toilette.
Außerdem klagt der Patient über Fieber mit 38 Grad, Vertigo und Nausea.
Der Patient teilt mit, dass er unter Bauchschmerzen leidet.
Die Schmerzen sind im Ganzunterbauch.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde von Patienten 5 bis 6 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala bewertet.
Der Patient gab an, dass die Diary wasrig und überwiegend ist.
Nach Angaben des Patienten wurde bei den Patienten vor zwei Wochen gegen Bronchitis eine Antibiotische Therapie durchgeführt.
Die Fragen nach Hemathemes, Melena und einer bestimmten Auslöser wurden verneint.
Die Vegetative Anemnese ist unauffällig bis auf Inapetens.
Im Besuch auf Vorerkrankungen leidet der Patient seit 20 Jahren an Arteriellhypertonie, seit 10 Jahren an Gonathros.
Bei den Patienten wurde in seiner Kindheit eine Apendektomie durchgeführt.
Besuchlichtermedikation nimmt er am Lotipin 5 mg morgens und abends, Ibuprofen 400 mg morgens und abends, sowie Pantoprasol 20 mg morgens ein.
Bei den Patienten sind keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Warum nimmt der Patient Pantoprazole ein?
Wegen Magenschutz. Der Patient nimmt mehrmals Analgetikum und Ibuprofen ein.
Deswegen nimmt der Patient diese Medikamente.
Die Niko-Tin-Konsum, Alkoholkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint. Eltern von Patienten sind gesund. Er ist ein Einzelkind.
Die Eltern sind gesund?
Beide Eltern sind gesund.
Leben die noch?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Wahrscheinlich ist er schon gestorben.
Ja, richtig. Ich werde diese Frage bei der Untersuchung nachholen.
Herr Schmidt ist verheiratet und hat drei gesunde Kinder.
Zurzeit ist er Rentner, aber früher hat er als Altenpfleger gearbeitet.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unaufwendig. Er ist vollständig genügt.
Er geht spazieren.
Herr Oberas, die anamnestischen Angaben...
War er schon beim Hausarzt gewesen?
Entschuldigung, bitte?
War er wegen den Beschwerden schon bei seinem Hausarzt gewesen?
Nein, Herr Schmidt hat im Laufe der Zeit nicht andere Hausarzt aufgesucht.
Okay.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine akute Gastroenteritis hin,
da der Patient typische Symptome aufweist, zum Beispiel mehrere Diarrhoes und Fieber und ganzes, die Physiopädie, Bauchschmerzen.
Als differenziale Diagnosen kommen in chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankung.
Ist in ihm alt, aber selten, 71 Jahre alt.
Selten.
Ja.
Gar nicht.
Ja, richtig.
Und eine Divertikulitis.
Ja, kann sein, aber Divertikulitis macht normalerweise nicht diese hohen Durchfälle.
Gastroenteritis war richtig oder Enteritis war richtig, denke ich, aber was für ein Enteritis könnte das sein? Ganz typisch.
In diesem Fall?
Ja, in diesem Fall.
Vor zwei Wochen hat der Patient eine antibiotische Antibiotikum verarbeitet oder? Nein.
Er hat erhalten, eine antibiotische Therapie erhalten.
Ja, erhalten. Deswegen können wir eine antibiotische Nebenwirkung von antibiotischen sagen.
Keine Nebenwirkung, nicht eine Nebenwirkung, aber eine sogenannte antibiotika-associierte Enteritis gibt es.
In Deutschland sehr oft, muss man sagen, bei älteren Patienten.
Welche, wie nennt man diese Enteritis? Sie hat einen bestimmten Namen.
Übel riechende Durchfälle, häufiger, hohes Alter nach Antibiotika-Gabe. Wie nennt man diese?
Eine Pseudomembranösekulitis bzw. Clostridien-Enteritis, durch Clostridien verursacht. Kennen Sie das?
Meinen Sie als Erreger?
Richtig.
Ja, Clostridium difficile.
Clostridium difficile bzw. Clostridium difficile Toxin. Richtig, kennen Sie das?
Nein, ganz typisch. Hohes Alter, Krankenhausaufenthalt, Antibiotikum, hat sogar Pantoprazole, Kinder mit Ziehen bekommen.
Das sind alles so Faktoren, die für eine Clostridien-Enteritis sprechen.
Vielen Dank für diese Informationen.
Was machen wir denn mit den Patienten zur Diagnostik?
Zunächst würde ich bei den Patienten die Vitalparameter kontrollieren und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die Haut von Patienten inspizieren.
Außerdem würde ich bei der körperlichen Untersuchung ob Abwechslpannung, Druckdolenz, Dostlastschmerz oder Organemagalie vorlegen.
Richtig.
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich eine Labountersuchung durchführen.
Und Blutbild-Ersundung-Parameter, CRP, Nieren- und Leberwerte und Stullprobe.
Elektrolyte nicht vergessen, ganz wichtig. Der Patient hat Durchfall, er verliert viele Salze.
Elektrolyte bestimmen lassen. Nach der Labountersuchung würde ich eine Abdomenssonographie durchführen.
Richtig.
Um die inneren Organe zu beurteilen.
Ja, was noch?
Zu beurteilen.
Natürlich würde ich eine digitale und rechte Untersuchung durchführen.
Haben Sie das immer, wenn jemand Durchfall hat?
Entschuldigung.
Machen Sie das immer, wenn jemand Durchfall hat?
Oder warum machen Sie das?
Der Patient ist alt.
Ja, kann man machen.
Wenn man die Differenzialdiagnose stenozierender Tumor hat, der auch Durchfall machen kann, kann man machen.
Welche Diagnostik machen Sie noch?
Der Durchfall.
Ja, ich würde eine Computerisierte Tomographie des Abdomens.
Nein, Durchfall.
Durchfall?
Was machen Sie?
Ich habe einen Stullprobetest bestimmen lassen.
Genau, eine Stullprobe.
Und was lassen Sie kontrollieren?
In der Stullprobe?
Ja, bei der Stullprobe kontrolliere ich Erreger.
Erreger, ganz genau.
Und Blut.
Auch, was noch?
Sie können auch Entzündungsparameter messen.
Meinen Sie Lokosythen?
Teil Protektin.
Teil Protektin gibt es.
Das ist ein Marker, der im Darm produziert wird, ob eine Entzündung vorliegt oder nicht.
Können Sie nochmal nachlesen.
Teil Protektin.
Aber Sie lassen natürlich auch Clostridin bestimmen, weil Sie haben den Verdacht, auf eine Clostridin entdeckt zu sein.
Ja, bei der Stullprobe können wir die Erreger feststellen.
Und was machen Sie therapeutisch bei den Patienten?
Herr Oberath, sollte sich meine Verdachtstheramose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Die Stullprobe haben Sie ja noch nicht sofort.
Stullprobe dauert zwei Tage.
Nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf oder nicht?
Ja, ja. Der Patient hat mehr Diäre.
Deswegen hat der Patient mehr oder zu viel Flüssigkeit verloren.
Genau. Was müssten Sie denn machen?
Deswegen würde ich den Patienten ausreichende Flüssigkeit oder massive Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Wie denn? Drinken oder intravenös?
Ein Venös an Zugang legen.
Dabei würde ich Antibiotikum und Antiemetikum.
Und gegen Klebsiala eine Antibiotikum verabreichen.
Keine Antibiotikum mehr ein seit zehn Tagen.
Aber würden Sie jetzt schon Antibiotikum geben, ohne zu wissen, was er hat?
Ja, deswegen würde ich eine Antibiotik-Kultur.
Ja genau, haben Sie ja gemacht. Stullprobe.
Aber dauert zwei Tage. Sie wissen es noch nicht.
Sie wissen noch nicht, ob er Kostriden hat oder etwas anderes.
Ein Antibiotikum jetzt schon geben würde ich nicht machen.
Ich würde eine Antibiotikum geben, wenn Sie das Ergebnis haben. Also noch zwei Tage.
Aber dahin können Sie schon intravenöse Flüssigkeitzugabe geben. Das reicht schon aus.
Und natürlich würde ich eine sehr hohe Entzündungswerte haben.
Sehr hohe. Da kann man Antibiotikum überlegen.
Ja, deswegen würde ich eine symptomatische Therapie behandeln.
So, dann nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf.
Ja, natürlich.
Was müssen Sie bei dem Patienten aufpassen, wenn Sie ihn stationär aufnehmen?
Er hat Durchfall. Er muss also isoliert werden.
Der Patient muss stationär isoliert werden, allein im Zimmer.
Ja, ja.
Ganz wichtig.
Jetzt haben wir zwei Tage das Ergebnis mit Kostriden entterritten.
Welches Antibiotikum geben Sie dann?
Kostridium.
Dann geben Sie Bancomycin.
Was?
Bancomycin.
Ja, wenn wir Erreger feststellen.
Wenn wir Kostridium-Verdacht bestätigt haben, dann ja.
Dann bekommt er Bancomycin.
Okay?
Ja, nach der Akutbehandlung empfehlen wir den Patienten personische Hygiene, gesunde Ernährung.
Das empfehlen wir sowieso.
Das hat nichts mit Ernährung zu tun.
Kostridium hat nichts mit Ernährung zu tun.
Hat mit Antibiotika zu tun.
Ja, ja.
Okay?
Unsere Händeflüssigkeit trinken.
Kostridium wird mit Antibiotika behandelt.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Okay. Also, Patienten stationär aufnehmen, Flüssigkeit geben,
Blutwerte kontrollieren, Stuhlprobe kontrollieren.
Wenn die Stuhlprobe positiv auf Kostridium ist, Antibiotikum geben.
Ja, als Antibiotikum würden wir Bancomycin...
Ganz genau. Wir geben Bancomycin für mindestens 10 Tage.
Okay?
Okay.
Gibt es Fragen?
Muss Bancomycin im Krankenhaus weitergeben?
Vor- oder seit 3 Tagen?
Ja.
Oral. Nicht vor- oder vor-hinsichtlich.
Ah, oral.
Okay.
Muss Arzt Leben oder Nierenwerte kontrollieren,
gleichzeitig Bancomycin?
Natürlich.
Welche Werte?
Welche Leben oder Nieren?
Die beiden.
Beide Werte.
Und normalerweise, vielleicht falsch weiß ich,
normalerweise nach dem Antibiotikum nutzen, warten wir die Arten ungefähr innerhalb 3 Tagen.
Ja.
Aber dieser Mann, ungefähr vor 2 Wochen Antibiotikum nutzen,
aber nicht innerhalb 3 Tagen hat er Durchfall.
Ja, normalerweise ist das früher, haben Sie recht, innerhalb von 3-5 Tagen,
aber dieser Partie hat man später bekommen. Man muss also dran denken.
Ja.
Okay. Wie kann man zum Beispiel Vibrio cholera auszuschließen?
Können Sie auch Stuhlprobe machen?
Nur Stuhlprobe. Okay.
Aber Cholera ist sehr selten in Deutschland.
Ja.
Begleit vielleicht, aber nicht hier.
Oder, und vielleicht mehr erhöhte Fieber mit Cholera oder?
Cholera ist selten in Deutschland, der war nicht im Ausland gewesen.
Vorher soll er Cholera bekommen.
Es gibt keine erhöhte Infektionszahlen hier in Deutschland.
Okay.
Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich Kostridien.
Er kann auch Salmonellen haben, Salmonellen zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Ohne Blut.
Aber das macht nicht die Oberdurchfallrate und auch nicht diese Beschwerden.
Okay.
Ist es hilfreich, dass Probiotikum anfangen oder?
Vielleicht.
Okay. Danke.
Entschuldigung.
Die Diagnose ist Kostridien enttäuscht.
Oder Pseudomembranose-Kolitis.
Wenn man es nicht weiß.
Normalerweise erwarten wir die Fieber beim Pseudomembranose-Kolitis.
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Normalerweise erwarten wir Fieber beim Pseudomembranose-Kolitis.
Ist das normal?
Ja, ja.
Wegen der Hydratation vielleicht.
Bitte?
Fieber, Fieber, Aufgrundfieber, vielleicht auch die Hydratation.
Natürlich, ganz genau.
Und wenig trinken.
Er ist auch nicht jung.
Er ist älter, 71 Jahre alt.
Dann vergisst man auch trinken manchmal.